Hey guys,
Let's talk about sex.
Yes, you heard me right.
And for all of those of you who might be
surprised or shocked that I'm going to talk
about sex, let me just make this clear.
The whole world is talking about sex.
In magazines, in books,
on social media, in entertainment, in school.
They talk about it.
And most kids hear about it from their
friends at school, many years too early.
So let me ask you... why should
Christian preachers not talk about sex
and why are others not doing it?
Because they are scared of what people will say.
Because we as true Christians - children of
God - and especially preachers - we need to
talk about these things in truth and in love.
And let me tell you this - the Bible has a great
deal to say about sex.
For example:
[Proverbs 5:18-19]
Wow.
Is this the Bible?
Yes it is the Bible.
A lot of people don't even know this.
The Bible talks a lot about sex.
And you know, John the Baptist,
he did not keep quiet about sex.
He spoke the truth and he was
beheaded because he would not compromise on
God's moral law, and we should do the same.
We should not be fearful.
We should speak the
truth in boldness but also in love.
So today, I'm gonna be straight with you guys
and because we are men, we need
to talk about these things.
I'm going to be frank about sex.
We're going to take a look at
scripture and we're going to talk about sex.
What the Bible says about sex, in a healthy way.
First, you need to understand that God
created sex for good, not for evil.
And you can see that back in Genesis, God blessed
Adam and Eve, and told them in Genesis 1 verse 28:
In other words, He told them have sex.
Have children.
It was meant for good.
There was nothing strange or shameful about it.
Lustful in a sinful way.
No.
It is meant to be good and
honorable within marriage.
[Hebrews 13:4]
You know, God gave us the desire to have sex.
And just think about it, if if He
didn't, you know we would cease to exist.
We would not have sex, we would not have
any children, and we would just die out.
And I agree with Billy Graham, who said that God
gave man, mankind, three main reasons to have sex.
One, to propagate the human race.
Two, for the climax of true love within marriage.
And three, sex was given so that a man and a
woman could express the unity between them.
And you can enjoy sex within marriage.
As we read in Proverbs.
But if that is the only reason you want to
have sex, just because of fleshly desire,
there's something wrong.
Because that's what the
world is making sex out to be today.
Just for one reason, and that is just lust.
It is for selfish pleasure and in a lot of
cases, they just use the other person as a prop,
not a human being.
Listen carefully.
Yes, God has given you the desire to have sex,
but with this desire comes a responsibility
to have self-control.
And if you cannot control yourself, then
what makes you different from an animal
that is just led by its emotions?
Just wants to have sex whenever it wants to?
You're a human being, made in an image of
God, and if you don't have self-control,
if you don't take responsibility for your own
actions, then you're a weak and selfish man.
[1 Thessalonians 4:3-5]
You know, a lot of men, they have the wrong
perception or understanding of what sex really is.
And it is not only wrong, it is dangerous.
Because it causes a lot of pain and
suffering in the world.
And that is why we need
to talk about this truthfully.
First, I said sex is not bad.
God created it to be enjoyed within marriage.
And second, it can be used for evil.
And when you look at the world,
it is mostly used for evil.
A lot of men today - they even boast about their
idolatry as if it's some kind of achievement.
They have no honor.
[Proverbs 6:32]
Any form of sex outside of marriage is wrong.
And when you do it - adultery - it's
not just causing harm to you.
Like this verse says in Proverbs - it
is also causing harm to your family.
It destroys families.
Let me ask some of you - how many of
you had a dad who cheated on their mom?
You found out - how did you feel about it?
Remember it and don't do it to your family.
[Genesis 2:24]
Not wives, not other women - your wife.
And they shall become one flesh.
Now the danger within marriage is also this
- a lot of people give in to temptation.
When the temptation is strong and
their self-control is weak - when
they act in the flesh - then they sin.
And that usually happens when they feel
that they're not being fulfilled in the marriage
for a long period of time, and then they start
looking at the other side of the grass.
And the grass looks greener, but it's not.
It's actually rotten.
[1 Corinthians 7:5]
You know, as a man, as the head of the family,
you need to make a point - I mean make effort -
to keep that spark in your relationship alive.
Take care of your body.
Eat healthy.
Work out.
Have sex and enjoy it.
Do you see?
Your desires - not
just with sex - but with all desires when it
comes to your relationship with your wife.
You know, and with sex you need
to be filled inside of marriage.
So that you don't go and
look for it at other places.
Because let me tell you, you won't find it.
And you know this is important because the
number one thing that men struggle
with - the number one sin - is lust.
And if you look at a history, even kings.
It doesn't matter who you are,
what type of man you are.
Most men, when you look at history, the one thing
that brought men down to their knees, was women.
Adam, who was tempted to sin by Eve in Genesis 3.
Abraham by Sarah in Genesis 16.
Samson by Delilah in Judges 16.
And the young man by a harlot - Proverbs 7.
And then also Joseph, by Potiphar's wife.
I'm mentioning Joseph because Joseph was one of
the few men who did not give in to temptation.
And at that moment, it wasn't even good for him.
Because he was put in prison.
But God used that situation for good, and at the
end, He put him in a power position so that he
could help the nation of Israel.
Do you see what I'm saying here?
A lot of men are struggling.
They fail, they fall into temptation
and they cheat on their partners.
And then they destroy their family.
And when we look at society today, we see
that there are broken - we are broken.
Society is broken because of broken families.
And a lot of them are broken not even by real
women - or women on pictures and videos -
because they're addicted to pornography.
God's word says:
[1Corinthians 6:18]
Now this is extremely serious for God.
He is very clear on sexual sin in the Bible.
And you need to understand this because
part of the reason I'm making this series
is because when we look at the world,
what is going on, it's getting worse.
You see the devil and his demons pulling the
strings of secret societies and leads who control
big corporations, the media, entertainment, even
trying to control the schools so that kids - young
kids - think that they are uncool if they
reach the age of 16 and they're still a virgin.
That they're being made fun of.
We are getting worse over time
because it used to be 18.
It used to be 21 before 18.
Do you see what I'm saying here?
And now we have even kids - 10 year
old kids - who are becoming pregnant.
The world is changing as we know it.
You think I'm joking?
I'm not.
Watch this.
Now the department said that
23,000 teen girls that had
fallen pregnant - some as young as the age of 10.
Wow, now this figure is up
from April 2020 to March 2021.
Thirteen year old Virginia has her
hands full, trying to comfort her
three-month-old baby - tending to house
chores - and her four younger siblings.
She was 12 when she became pregnant.
A few months ago, Lorena's
life was turned upside down.
At 15 she became a mother.
Ever since, she and her boyfriend
have faced constant challenges and are raising
their daughter Andrea in an abandoned building.
She's a baby.
But I'm just a child too.
I should have stayed at school.
You know, this is one of the reasons
why God is against sex before marriage.
Because a lot of men today without a
backbone - men without values - without
character - integrity - they make a woman
pregnant and then they just run away.
But it is their responsibility
to take care of that child.
There is a fatherless crisis
in the world and we men
are to blame.
Watch this:
Sixty percent of South Africa's
children have absent fathers.
More than 40 percent of South
African mothers are single parents.
Single motherhood in the black community
is at a staggering 74 percent today.
I'm guessing there will be no
committee hearings about that.
There are more black babies born.
There are more black babies aborted than
born alive in cities like New York and you
have Democrat Governor Andrew Cuomo lighting
up buildings to celebrate late term abortions.
You know, an absent father causes a lot
more harm that he would ever realize.
And listen to me today, if you know that you
have a child somewhere, go and make it right.
And if some of you are watching and you just
fathered a child, then take responsibility.
If you're scared that you're not
a good enough father, then learn.
Become better.
Let God change you.
Because you can change through
Christ who gives you strength.
And changing - starts with you taking
responsibility for your actions.
According to the U.S Census Bureau, 18.4
million children - one in four - live
without a biological step or
adoptive father in the home.
Fatherless societies affect the whole
world and increases the crime even.
I already told you that around
60 percent of the children in
South Africa grow up with absent fathers.
Let me show you how that impacts the crime.
According to worldpopulationreview.com,
South Africa has the third
highest crime rate in the world.
South Africa has a notably high rate of assaults,
rape, homicides and other violent crimes.
South Africa has one of the highest rape
rates in the world.
More than one in four
men surveyed by the South African Medical
Research Council admitted to committing rape.
You see, fatherlessness is one of the
highest causes of crime in the world.
Causing the most pain and suffering
than people can even imagine.
And why is nobody talking about this?
Here and there, some people are talking about
it - but the mass media definitely not.
Why not?
Why not deal with the problem?
Facts over feelings.
Yes, feelings are important,
but facts are more important.
And facts don't care about feelings.
What I mean is - if you go to the hospital
and you say, man, I have a headache.
Help me.
And he's like, nah,
here's just some pills so you can feel better.
It doesn't cure the problem.
You might need a surgery.
If you don't get it, you will die.
We need to talk about facts.
Listen to this: the U.S Department
of Health Statistics shows that
fatherlessness causes the following:
63 percent of youth suicides.
90 percent of all homeless and runaway children.
85 percent of all children
who show behavioral disorders.
80 percent of rapists with anger problems.
71 percent of high school student dropouts.
75 percent of adolescent patients
in chemical abuse centers.
85 percent of youths in prison.
And 71 percent of pregnant teenagers.
Look at all of these statistics
causing so much pain and suffering.
Oh yeah, but it's cool to brag
about how many women you slept with.
You are the man, right?
A real man takes care of his family.
He doesn't run away from his responsibilities.
A weak and pathetic man does.
Watch this from a former gang leader.
An increasing number of sickeningly violent
crimes is being committed by America's youth.
Why is this happening?
Is it a spiritual problem?
Family breakdown problem?
Is it a cultural problem?
Policing problem?
Or is it a combination of all of them?
Well the stories - the criminality
- seems to be getting worse.
Two Iowa teens have just been accused
of killing their 66 year old high
school Spanish teacher with a baseball bat.
In Minneapolis earlier this month, a 17 year
old was charged with shooting and killing a
man while he sat in his car at a gas station.
And last month a 19 year old was arrested
for the murder of a nine-year-old girl there.
Authorities have traced most of these
frightening cases to teens as young as 13.
Joining me now is John Turnip Seed,
former gang leader, drug dealer and pimp.
He's also the Executive Vice
President of Urban Ventures.
John, why is this happening?
You're based in Minneapolis.
We always think of Minnesota nice.
But what's driving the violence?
Well, one of the things - this is
sort of the aftermath of George Floyd.
You know, when that happened
and all the lawlessness came in,
kids got a sense of empowerment.
And you know, all of a sudden, we're backing off,
you know, arresting people for certain things.
And things of that nature, well kids, you know
who have a rebel spirit in them anyways, a lot
of times take advantage of this and now it's it's
sweeping the country. And kids will follow trends.
At one time,
we had kids that would knock people out.
See if they could knock people out with one blow.
This is not funny.
Where are all the fathers... men training boys
to become men of good character. Where are you?
Why do you just leave your boys alone?
That is just pure evil.
And if you're still alive
and if your boys are still alive,
there's still time to make this right.
Linking fatherlessness with sex - because no one
is talking about this - and the two are connected.
Because it seems like we as a society, as the
human race, we're not taking responsibility.
The decisions we make and the consequences
that comes from those decisions.
You get weak men who don't
care about the consequences.
They just want to have sex and pleasure.
Just so selfish, self-centered.
And then they just run away.
They have one night stands and they impregnate
women and then they just leave them alone.
How can you just vanish like that?
What is wrong with you?
On entertainment, you always
see shows where a group of guys is going out
and having a competition of who can get laid.
It is all about sex, pleasure, and
no responsibility that comes with it.
Guys, listen up.
It is easy just to give in
to your sinful flesh, right?
Your sexual desires.
It is easy, and that's why it
doesn't make you cool, or the man.
Because anyone can do it.
But it takes a good man of character to
discipline himself, to have self-control.
The Bible says:
[2 Timothy 2:22]
[1 Corinthians 6:18]
It doesn't say be led by your
sinful desires - it says flee.
Don't walk closer and inspect
it and play around with it.
It says flee.
That means turn around and run.
Especially when it comes to women.
Sex.
Wait for the right woman and then you can have as
much sex as you want and enjoy it within marriage.
And if you want to stay single then you can
do that but if you are burning with desire
and you know this is the woman God
wants you to marry, then do it.
Paul says:
[1 Corinthians 7:8]
The world says have as much sex
as you want before marriage.
Yeah you can get AIDS.
Yeah you can get children.
And yeah there's a lot of
problems that can come with it.
But just do what you want.
No consequences.
That's what the world feels and thinks
and you see it on TV all the time.
And it's... it's gross.
The Bible says no, we want healthy societies.
Men of character, women of character
who have sex inside marriage.
And we take care of their children.
A healthy family.
There is a reason why
you don't want to have sex with a lot of women
before marriage because you're gonna carry those
experiences with you into the marriage.
With all that baggage you're gonna go
in the marriage and for a lot of men it is
hard. They struggle with it those memories.
[1 Corinthians 7:1]
If you're not married yet,
then please listen to me.
As a married man, I've been married for 13 years,
and I spoke with a lot of other men
who've been married for longer than me.
And the advice that we're going to give
you is not just ah, stupid old people, no.
This is important because a lot
of people make the same mistakes
and you can never go back and change it.
You can ask God for forgiveness, right?
But you can't change it.
You've done it.
So we're telling you these things so you
don't make the mistakes because when you
are married later, you will regret it.
Not just because it is wrong, but because
those memories and experiences can
be a problem for your marriage.
Because you take that baggage with you.
Also, think about it this way.
Do you want to marry a woman....
you've not slept with any woman....
but she slept with a lot of guys?
How does that make you feel right now?
Not good, right?
You don't feel good about that.
And there's a lot of you men that want
to sleep with a lot of women, right?
And then you want to marry a woman
who's not slept with other guys.
Does that make sense to you?
You need to be pure as well.
The reason?
Because it feels dirty when
you think about those things inside us.
Because God has given all mankind
a moral code inside of them.
You know, what is right and what is wrong.
It's actually disgusting, because
sex is not just a physical bond,
it is an emotional and spiritual union.
That is why if you sleep with a Satanist,
those demons can go into you as well.
It happened when I was younger.
My dad prayed for a woman that
exactly that happened to her.
Every time the husband would
come back from truck driving.
She would just attack him.
They didn't know what was going on.
They prayed for them and the demon manifested sex.
It's not just, oh it's going to be sex, no it's
much more than that.
It is sacred.
God created it between a man
and a woman within marriage.
And marriage is to be held
in honor among all things.
Look, when it comes to sex, the
Bible makes the following very clear.
Number one: sex before marriage is wrong.
Two: sex outside of marriage is wrong.
Three: sex with an animal is wrong.
Four: rape is wrong.
Five: sex with close relatives is wrong.
Six: same sex is wrong.
Seven: Thinking about any of the above
and imagining how you do it - is wrong.
You know, sex is so sacred, marriage is so
sacred, and that's why Jesus said it's not
just about what you do, it's about
what you think - your intentions.
[Matthew 5:27]
And yes, this includes pornography.
This includes masturbating.
And let me make this very clear.
Marriage is amazing if it's
done within the will of God.
If the man is a Godly man, if the
woman is a Godly woman, you'll have
an amazing time and the sex is also great.
You can have sex within marriage and enjoy it,
because the marriage is honorable among all.
[Hebrews 13:4]
You need to understand that marriage
is not just how it's marriage.
It is important because marriage between a man and
a woman also symbolizes our relationship with God.
Listen to this:
[Ephesians 5:22-24]
Let me just quickly pause here because a
lot of guys think that they are the boss.
Wow, I'm the head of the family.
No, you don't understand.
What it means is that Christ
is the head of the church,
leading it in a loving way, in a truthful way.
But also sacrificing His own life for the church.
He also said that He came to serve.
So, if you lead your wife gently in love to
obey God's Word, then she needs to listen too.
Because ultimately then she listens to God's Word.
But if you lead her and you say she's got to
do things that are in contrast with scripture,
she doesn't need to listen to you.
She needs to listen to God,
but if you gently lead her, you're not the boss.
You're a leader and if you do so in love and in
truth according to scripture she will follow you.
Because ultimately she's following God.
[ Ephesians 5:25-33]
Now, let me make this clear.
The reason why so many people
today want to have sex in the wrong
way is because they are against God.
Their fleshly, sinful nature wants to do sin.
And sin is rebelling against God.
It's a disease, and this disease is in all of us.
[Romans 3:23]
This sin affects your mind - the
intellectual life of men - this is
why so many men cannot understand the things
of God until they give their lives to Christ.
And the Holy Spirit reveals
the truth of the Bible to you.
[2 Corinthians 4:4]
Sin affects your whole life,
because it separates you from God.
Your body is alive, but your soul, your
spirit, is dead to the things of God.
And you do not understand it
because your mind is darkened
and this is the reason why so many men out
there do not find real joy - real peace.
They try with things like sex
with different women but they
will never be satisfied.
Always hungry for more.
And maybe they go to other things like
money - drugs - alcohol - and even games.
You do these things because you try to
escape - you try to forget - but you can't.
That's why it is a chase after
nothingness, a chase after your own tail.
Because we were created to
have fellowship with God.
And if you don't have fellowship
with God, you will never have peace.
That is why you have this void,
this emptiness inside of you.
You try to fill it with temporary
things, but it cannot fill you.
Temporary material things of
this world cannot fill you.
You need the eternal.
You need the Spirit of God Himself.
This is why you see these
celebrities who are so empty.
They're just selling sex all the time.
But they are so empty - why?
You would think that they
have it all together, right?
They have fame - they have riches - they
have luxury - they have everything that
this world can give them.
And yet they are empty.
Most of them are miserable, depressed.
They have one divorce after the other.
Addicted to drugs and the list just goes on.
It's because they are spiritually dead,
separated from God.
And it is only God
that can make you spiritually alive.
It will give you that kind of water,
where you will never thirst again.
That's what Jesus meant when he said:
[John 4:13]
If you are dead to the things of God, but you
want to know - you want to understand - you're
thirsty - if you want to know more,
then please watch these videos here,
so that you will have water
and never thirst again.
I'll see you there.
And always remember, life is short.
So don't waste yours.
Bye.